dernières consignes de l'entraîneur
alexis dû monter avant le match le plus
important de l'année pour les moins de
13 ans de l'équipe de maurepas en cas de
victoire ce samedi contre le chesnay
versailles ses joueurs pour de sauver le
titre de champion la concentration est
maximale pendant le match comme sur les
dernières rencontres les mort patients
dominé remporte cette première période
27 à treize et je vous dirai je veux un
sans faute en championnat avec 9
victoires en 9 matches disputés les
résultats acquis grâce au travail de
l'entraîneur sont les parents des
joueurs ont senti une les aime pas de
chouchou est très juste et et droit dans
ses baskets donc c'est parfait c'est sur
steam collectif qui ressort plus de
cette équipe et tout le monde peut
prendre la place de tout le monde est un
bon goût qui s'est formé mon repas
s'impose finalement 47 à 31 contre son
adversaire du jour en maîtrisant la
seconde période à l'expérience
c'est officiel les norvégiens sont
champions
on joue un peu on est fiers monétiser
nos entraînements c'est qu'elle
travaille on a beaucoup couru et un
bonne équipe en tout cette année c'est
deux ans de travail
l'année dernière on avait fini troisième
en sept avions fini champions dont il ya
comme une belle marge de progression
c'est super de trois émotions sont
encore à prévoir dans les prochaines
semaines pour le bc maurepas avec cette
victoire la section jouera la finale
régionale pour le titre ibf de france
les joueurs eux ne sont pas prêts à
redescendre de leur nuage